foreign
spiritual practices are about connection
and connection is what makes us feel
happy on the whole whereas disconnection
separation alienation is what makes
people feel miserable on the whole
and
so singing and chanting and you know
they have physiological effects lower
cortisol levels stress hormone levels
and so on
um and there are some people including
actually Charles Darwin who suggested
that humans sang together before they
spoke that singing comes before speaking
and actually that's now born out by
modern evolutionary biology theories and
I I think it's the most plausible
explanation uh early human groups
achieved a kind of coherence and
synchronization through singing and
dancing and speaking was a kind of
spin-off from the singing singing came
first
fasting is another spiritual practice I
discuss in my book ways to go beyond
um all Traditions have it and and it
brings about measurable physiological
changes I'm also fast during Holy Week
before Easter every year for four days
or or so just water and tea and what
that does is causes the the body to
burn up the available sugar supplies in
the liver the the straws of
carbohydrates are exhausted within about
12 hours and then you're burning up fats
you go into ketosis and one of the
ketones in the blood is uh beta
hydroxybutyric acid which is very
closely related to gamma hydroxybutyric
acid a neurotransmitter which is in the
brain and Gamma aminobutyric acid which
is a neurotransmitter and the the the it
change Alters the state of mind so
fasting is is psychoactive it also
removes senescent cells from the body
that cause inflammation it's very good
for physical health for most people not
advisable for anorexic Advanced
diabetics and so on but for many people
it's the cheapest and simplest way of
improving physical health as well as
spiritual and mental health
of course that is not something much
most people do research on there's
nothing in this for food companies or
for drug companies and so it tends to be
neglected but if I ran the NHS I'd roll
out fasting counselors and promote
fasting for many people in the
population but the cheapest and simplest
intervention to improve National Health
and it'll because it leads to a greater
Clarity of mind it helps for prayer and
meditation and people often have more
vivid dreams
well there are many other spiritual
practices including Collective
celebrations through festivals and again
festivals in all cultures have a way of
bringing people together that sense of
bonding and Community I lived seven
years in India and I was very impressed
by the way in which they really take
their Festival seriously there and
everyone's involved the children the
whole community
and it's a way in which people gain
identity cohesion and connection with
the community
And Then There are a range of other
spiritual practices
um I'll just mention one because it's so
one more because it's slightly
surprising namely Sports
I think that sports are one of the most
common and yet least appreciated
spiritual practices in our culture and
the reason people I think are so fond of
sports apart from just feeling fit and
the excitement of competitive games and
so on is because they bring people into
the present I first realized this when
talking to a friend in America who had a
very busy life and told me that his mind
was racing all the time he couldn't
sleep at night he tried meditation it
didn't work for him but he was a rock
climber he said by the time he was 50
feet up a rock face the only thing that
mattered was where the next toe holds
and finger holds were and he was
completely in the present if you're in
the middle of a football game and people
are cheering on and the ball's being
passed you and stuff you have to be
completely present you can't be worrying
about what you didn't do yesterday or
what you might do tomorrow meditation is
about coming into the present but Sports
bring people into the present even
Spectators
much more effectively and quickly I
think and I think it's one reason so
many people do them and One Reason by
many why many people actually have
spiritual experiences this sense of
presence and connection through Sports
what I mainly want to focus on though is
these spiritual practice of pilgrimage
which is present in all cultures
um there's we find it in India in in
Buddhist countries people go to places
where the Buddha was born or was
enlightened mainly in India
um we find it in Islam with pilgrimages
to
um the Mecca and to other holy places
and of course in the Christian tradition
medieval Europe was crisscrossed with
pilgrimage Roots here in England the
most famous was the pilgrimage to
Canterbury to the shrine of Thomas
Beckett
and I think the pilgrimage fulfills a
very deep archetypal human need our
ancestors were all hunter-gatherers they
moved around the landscape they went to
uh on their Journey the Australian
average Aborigines called these song
lines they tell the story they sing the
story of the key places they visited on
the journey
and if your hunter-gatherers you have to
move around because animals and plants
don't just come to you fruit doesn't
just drop into your lap and the Animals
you eat don't just come and meekly offer
themselves up to be sacrificed you have
to move around with the seasons and so
this moving and reaching significant
places is fundamental to our whole
ancestral history and I think when
Neolithic Revolution occurred when
people settled down and began
agriculture they still had holy places
they went to especially for special
seasonal festivals Stonehenge being one
example it was not in the middle of a
city but people converged on Stonehenge
for these festivals a little bit like
today people converge on Glastonbury for
the Glastonbury Festival I think in
sense these Summer music festivals have
reinvented some of these ancient
festivals
well in England there were many shrines
one of them was the shrine of our the
black Madonna in Walsingham the um uh
Shrine of the Blessed Virgin Mary
um but at the Protestant Reformation
um pilgrimage in England was suppressed
in 1538 Thomas Cromwell issued an
injunction against pilgrimage made it
illegal to go on pilgrimage the shrines
were desecrated the monasteries that
provided the infrastructure for pilgrims
where they could sleep and get fed that
were destroyed the shrine of Our Lady of
Walsingham was destroyed the image of
our lady was burned in a public bonfire
and one reason they were so against the
cult of our lady was because they said
that treating Saint Mary as the mother
of God was basically a Resurgence of
ancient goddess Cults and this was
basically Pagan well I think that's the
great strength of the cult of the
Blessed Virgin Mary precisely that it is
inherits many of these goddess elements
anyway they didn't like it and they
suppressed pilgrimage in England which
left a great void in the soul of the
English
um it was suppressed in Wales and
Scotland as well and in other processing
countries it left a great void and I
think that's why the English invented
tourism
tourism is best seen as a form of
secularized pilgrimage
um tourists still go to the great holy
places the cathedrals the temples and so
forth but being tourists they have to
pretend that their Enlightenment modern
secular people they're basically going
out of a deep interest in art history
rather than going there to light a
candle or say a prayer or or
address the god or the goddess or the
spirit of the place
and in fact it's very unsatisfying all
they can do is take photos
um so I think actually pilgrimage is
best seen as frustrated pilgrimage
and I think one of the Paradigm shifts
that's going on today is the shift from
tourism to pilgrimage going back to
pilgrimage
there's an enormous Revival of
pilgrimage going on in Europe at the
moment
the most famous iconic pilgrimage place
is Santiago de compostelo in Spain and
some of you may have been there
in 1987 when the route was newly opened
up and they'd got the infrastructure in
place about 1 000 people walked there in
2019 it was 330 000 people that walked
to Santiago to Compostela and as a
result of that all over Europe there's
been a Revival of pilgrimage here in
Britain there's an organization called
the British pilgrimage trust which is
reopening the ancient footpath
pilgrimage routes to Canterbury and to
other ancient holy places
in the last two years they've opened a
short one-day pilgrimage Roots five or
six miles to all 42 of the cathedrals in
England
there's a major route being developed at
the moment from Ireland walking through
Ireland getting the ferry across to
Wales and then to the great Senate the
most important cathedral in Wales and
David's it here's David's Cathedral
there are a number of other pilgrimage
routes being developed and opened up
here in Britain at the moment and if
you're interested in this I'd strongly
recommend going to the website
britishpilgrimage.org where you can find
details of these routes
now holy places can be many and varied
in Britain because of our history
they're mainly Cathedrals and churches
they're also holy Wells sacred trees
mountaintops sources of rivers and these
pilgrimage Roots include all those kinds
of holy places
and holy places all over the world have
been seen as joining points Between
Heaven and Earth and they're typically
associated with vertical structures
there are some like caves which are not
where you're going into the bowels of
the Earth but many of them were standing
stones with obelisks with tires and
spiers
structures where the symbolically the
structure points up into the heaven and
links the Heaven and the Earth but it's
more than just symbolic because these
vertical structures actually attract
lightning lightning doesn't just strike
at random it strikes at the highest
places and when you put metal lightning
conductors on them they become even more
attractive to lightning so basically our
holy places like Towers church towers
and spiers and and prominent standing
stones and other holy places actually
funnel lightning into the ground in that
place they collect it from quite a wide
radius and channels into the ground in
that Holy place so they are literally
places where the energy of the heavens
which comes from the solar wind through
the ionosphere down through Sprites to
the clouds and then into the ground is
coming into the Earth
no one in Britain seems to know how
often these stroke buildings are struck
but I've discovered in France there's a
company that makes lightning strike
counters which you clip on the lightning
conductor you bolt them on and they're
electromechanical very satisfyingly they
don't require batteries because when you
have a million volts going down the
lightning conductor you can use the free
Power that makes these things work and
every time enlightening a strike goes
down the conductor a mechanical digital
thing moves over one click and so it
would say five and there's lightning
strike then it'll say six so you can
monitor when they occur and actually in
France I discovered by law all churches
Cathedrals and other Hotel structures
have to make an annual report of how
many lightning strikes they've had
there's somewhere in France there's a
database with this amazing information
and as far as I know no one's looked at
it or analyzed it but it would be very
fascinating to do that
I've imported some of these lightning
strike counters and several are going to
be fitted on Parish churches in the next
few weeks as a pilot scheme and um I'm
already in discussion with the
association of English Cathedrals to see
if we can have them fitted on all our
Cathedrals the average Cathedral has
about five lightning conductors from the
various towers and so on and
um
that could be monitored it all could all
be online you know whenever they're
struck by lightning a really interesting
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas